VERIFY THE NUMBERS.
THE COMMITTEE, TO PREDICT THE
JOURNALIST, SAY THAT 20
JOURNALISTS HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
NO BY IRANIAN AUTHORITIES AMID
THE PROTESTS.
U.S. ARCHITECT OF, STATE
ANTHONY BLINKEN, SAYS THAT THE
UNITED STATES WILL PROVIDE
PAKISTAN WITH TELL MILLION
DOLLARS OF AID FOR FOOD
SECURITY IN THE CATASTROPHIC
FLOODING.
LIKE I, SAID SUPPLIES WILL HELP
FARMERS RECOVER SUCH ITEMS,
SEEDS AND FERTILIZERS.
NOW, THE EXTREME FLOODING HAS
CLAIMED 16 LIVES.
OUR REPORT NOW FROM ANA.
CORN.
>> IN THE SCORCHING HEAT, A
COUPLE CARRY THEIR LISTLESS
CHILD TOWARDS A PACKED WOODEN
BOAT, FERRYING SICK VILLAGERS
THROUGH THE FLOODWATERS. THE
MOTHER GRABS HER DAUGHTER AND
FINDS A PLACE TO SIT. THE
EIGHT-YEAR-OLD IS BURNING UP.
SHE HAS A HIGH-GRADE FEVER AND
HAS BECOME UNCONSCIOUS,
EXPLAINS HER MOTHER. LET'S GO,
LET'S GO, YELLS A VILLAGER. THE
MOTHER THEN WETS HER DAUGHTER'S
BROW WITH THE VERY SAME WATER
THAT HAS MADE HER SO SICK.
PAKISTAN'S MONTH-LONG
CATASTROPHIC FLOOD WHICH
INUNDATED ONE THIRD OF THE
COUNTRY AFFECTING 33 MILLION
PEOPLE ARE STILL CAUSING
UNSPEAKABLE SUFFERING. THE
MONSOONAL RAINS MAY BE OVER,
BUT THE VOLUME OF STAGNANT
WATER IS NOW CAUSING A HEALTH
CRISIS, ESPECIALLY IN SINDH,
ONE OF THE WORST HIT PROVINCES
IN THE COUNTRY SOUTHEAST, CASES
OF CHOLERA, DANGUE AND
DEHYDRATION HAVE SURGED. >>
I'VE SEEN FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
CONSUME THE VERY FLOODWATER
THEY ARE SURROUNDED BY. BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO ANY
OF THE WATER SOURCE. >> AS THEY
REACH THE SHORE, IT IS A RACE
AGAINST TIME. THE NEAREST
HOSPITAL IS HOURS AWAY BY
RICKSHAW AND HER DAUGHTER'S
CONDITION IS WORSENING. THESE
YOUNG MOTHERS HAVE FOUND
MEDICAL CARE, ALTHOUGH THERE
ARE NEWBORNS BARELY HAVE THE
ENERGY TO CRY. THEY HAVE COME
TO THE MOTHER AND CHILD
HOSPITAL WHERE THE CRITICALLY
ILL OR TAKEN TO THE
RESUSCITATION WARD. A BABY'S
CHEST SLOWLY RISES AND FALLS OF
OXYGEN, PUMPED THROUGH A TUBE,
HELPS US INFANT TO BREATHE.
LYING BESIDE IT, THE BODY OF
ANOTHER BABY THAT DIDN'T MAKE
IT. FOR THE DOCTORS HERE, THIS
IS AGONIZING WORK. UP TO ONE
DOZEN CHILDREN ARE DYING EACH
DAY FROM FLOOD-RELATED ILLNESS,
WHICH IS UNHEARD OF IN THIS
SMALL HOSPITAL. >> THIS GIRL
HAS CHOLERA, SAYS DR. NAZIA
UROOJ, THEIR BODIES GO INTO
SHOCK. WE TRY TO REHYDRATE THEM
WITH THE FLUID THEY'VE LOST.
ONE OF THE FOUR CHILDREN
SHARING THIS BED APPEARS TO BE
GOING DOWNHILL RAPIDLY. HEART
MONITORS ARE PLACED ON THE
CHEST OF FIVE-YEAR-OLD IKRA,
WHO IS SEVERELY STUNTED. HER
HEART IS SLOWLY BEATING, BUT
HER EYES GLAZE OVER. MINUTES
LATER, SHE DIES. A NURSE
PREPARES HER TINY BODY FOR AN
ISLAMIC BURIAL, AS HER SISTER
AND GRANDMOTHER WEEP OUTSIDE.
OF THE MORE THAN 1500 PEOPLE
WHO DIED SINCE JUNE FROM
PAKISTAN'S CLIMATE CHANGE
-INDUCED CATASTROPHE, MORE THAN
ONE THIRD HAVE BEEN CHILDREN.
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS REMAIN
HOMELESS HAVING LOST HOMES,
CROPS AND LIVESTOCK. RANI IS
ONE OF THEM. SHE WONDERS IF THE
WATERS WILL ALSO TAKE HER